this footsteps outside the ship but
nothing's showing up on the
radar never mind it's a gigantic Red Dot
the biggest I've ever [__] seen Mark
you have that giant red circle on you
mark move Mark move oh oh oh my God oh
my God did you see it Mark I did not see
it I felt something pulling at my soul
what about those moons that we have to
pay for what are you know the Primo
moons the next time we get together we
definitely afford as long as we don't
screw today up we're crushing this this
is might be a $1,000 haul boys that was
a
$970
haul I say that's a good day and I think
it's the fitting start of a new chap is
that a
gun is that a
gun no it's a laser pointer but it's I
thought that was the moment of betrayal
where you were going to just shoot me
as I'm saying a new chapter on our life
I really hope lixian edits it so that's
like the end is that a
[Laughter]
gun Z Reynolds is that royan Reynolds is
that royan rynolds Ry reyns got to hit
the gritty
boys that hit the gritty how do
you oh my oh that's a good mod I got to
rejoin I'll be right back oh
boy ah this is this is great is this is
this doing what I think it's doing oh
it's doing it thumbnail right there mark
tws oh yeah Mark here you know do I look
like a minion to you kind of come here
Pi your poison oh God Pi your favorite
poison hey Ghostbusters nice yeah all
right I got some you guys want you guys
want to hear something cool sure
okay hold on you were right Ryan that's
not cool no hold on hold on hold
on wait wait for it okay can you hear
that tickity tack that's yeah what's
that yeah that's a guer
counter
ooh yeah yeah radio you got in your room
uh High uh 78 micro CTS per
hour that sounds like a lot of seabirds
I hate that you both have the eyeballs
but mine is fancy and do you like my hat
child yeah I thought you would find this
a lot more fascinating than it was
that's look it's background radiation
man I mean it's kind of like I hear the
little beeps here and there but without
being able to see what's going on it's
just like beeping nois okay all right
yeah just I have something radioactive
and you guys don't care about it but
whatever we don't see that we just hear
the noises yeah whatever you don't you
don't care podcast I can't see what
you're doing you don't care it's fine
the
podcast the podcast what all right um so
welcome back I guess to lethal company
yeah that's new I didn't do anything to
make any of this happen it was actually
Wade and no one would believe that if
you're an avid listener of the podcast
no one would ever believe
that to be fair I don't believe Wade
made this happen of his own accord I
believe he played with other people who
put this together and he just shared the
with us I don't want to cast dispersion
but is that is that is that
accurate all
right well what until next time I'll
give him see you guys credit well his
that was the shortest episode he's ever
done you going to milk this session into
an 80 part series I was going to try to
80 30 second Parts yeah I miss 10-minute
episodes anyone watch my videos how long
are they
see
we have 1400 Buck arinos we can go
somewhere cool oh we do yeah we have a
Teleport what do we have right now we
have a teleporter do we have any items
we probably have some walking oh look at
that look at the stuff we have
flashlights couple oh sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry I can't grab until the
ship is landed I'm sorry I'm sorry Mark
yeah no no I love you you're you're
beautiful all right thank you do you
want to see a new moon Mark
always oh whoa whoo whoo why whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey hey hey hey hey I
thought you were sending me to the
Moon all right that that would be a hell
of a trick I would love if that was what
was happening hey Martin you want see a
new moon uh yeah I
guess dude you got the most pronounced
hip bones of any human I've ever seen
look at those stabby [__] oh we all
have
that got like the most uncomfortable
looking ass cheeks never my yes thank
you
Yahoo Yahoo wait whoa hold on hold what
kind of what kind of wish.com Mario is
this wait hold on it's I'm sorry is this
is this your take on the Chris Pratt
Mario wo it's
me 85
Ren life to exist while we were waiting
for you Mark we added a couple mods that
we haven't even tried so uh let's hope
they're good where are we and why do I
care oh this is called Ren mark this is
called Ren what you really want to do is
follow the lights okay I can't see
anything get get your walkie Mark you
got your walkie yeah walkie check test
walkie check walkie check test so you
can when you have your walkie in the
slot you can hold you can just hit X to
walkie at any moment without having to
hold oh that's nice anyway uh wait do
you need where'd you get that it was
just on the Shelf oh well let's
go all right you know you know I kind of
get it about the not having a dedicated
walkie slot I like the action of having
to pull it out to talk but then but then
it's hard to talk sometimes yeah well
I'm still going to whip it out and have
to activate it just to play to the
authenticity of it all right well we'll
do a gentleman's agreement I'll do the
same I'll do the same wait so how do we
what we're just kind of going into the
storm with no
objective yeah you want to follow lights
same objective we always have blue for
the company for the company oh
hi the company thek come to the
company's voice all right oo whoa what
is what wait w w wa a minute nothing bad
will happen in here find loot yay okay
all right right
um I'll go this way I guess I'm going to
go upstairs I'm going to go see what's
upstairs okay fancy lamp holy crap oh
it's a two-handed thing dang it yeah no
it yeah it occupies your hand all right
there's like three down here I'm going
to pop them
outside this place is swimming in loot
this is this is a lot of money hey hey
found a present he found he found a bob
you should bring the present back to the
main entrance and open it with
us coming back to the main hall Bob I
thought I thought you were dead I really
thought
that oh okay I'm going to open the
present you guys ready
y that's a problem that's not my
favorite thing that's ever happened
there's a cup there's a cup get the cup
okay all right Mark you watch that and
I'm all right hello you know you
watch yeah I know I know what it's all
about I know you okay look like what
like a minion know wait the odds of that
are pretty slim I think hey guys I found
another present I'm going to come open
right next to where the other one was
hey Mark
look oh yeah good itop it yeah I'm going
to open it right here oh that's fine oh
that was a good present I hope that's
Wade behind me God that
flashlight so um I'm there's trle
there's trle outside okay that's bad why
are they out already that's so early
there's triple outside what do we do
about that we already have we actually
already have three loads of full loot
outside too
[__] do you want to look around a
little bit I can watch this or so you
can make a
round what what said I can watch this if
you want to make a round come on in Mark
the water's fine Bob was that you
playing with your soundboard Mark you
watch that and I'm going to leave uh
probably you know me Jesus Christ
someone was talking while Bob was
talking Bob was talking while Bob was
talking what huh are you [__] with me
yes Bob was talking yeah I was I was
just I was talking about the walkie the
podcast oh hey look it's a ghost girl
what wait can you see the ghost girl
yeah I have to look at this thing what
do you mean is there something behind me
turn around turn around Mark there's a
ghost behind you what do you mean
looking at I'm looking at it oh she
walked away what do you mean what do you
mean what do you mean
oh it's fine Mark we're looking at the
thing you can that's probably
fun wait did Mark just talk while Mark
was talking I don't I
on the Shelf what should we leave I feel
like we ghost moved ghost moved wait is
it looking atep outside I think we
should probably all step outside is
looking oh wait it's looking at you Mar
I'll watch the I'll watch the thing you
go outside Mark you go okay all right
I'm going outside all right oh okay I
got wait oh hey okay get inside get
inside get inside no
I'm running for my life I don't know
where I'm going I found a building I'm
going to try to get
shelter I made it into a building I
don't know where I
am don't worry it's
fine okay um yeah I kind of ran headlong
into the blizzard I did what you
shouldn't do in horror
games oh my God please tell me that's
one of you is that one of
you Mark if you go out of that building
go to the right uh go
on okay go straight go straight that
direction that you're
facing what in the holy hell was
that I don't know but I heard it too
Mark you need to come out you need to
get to the ship all
right oh my God oh my
God hey you're here you're
here oh my God okay I heard I heard that
Bob was that B I hate to tell you but um
B's dead he got eaten right in front of
my eyes oh okay well let's go um unless
you think I can go get
loot uh guys can you come oh my god do
you see anything out here I'm
everything's getting funky it's very
foggy what do you
mean we should go we we should just go
why are we here
yeah we should go let me get his
body oh okay no we're good we're good
we're good wait I'm going to go get I'm
going to get Bob's body back and we're
going to get out of here uh he's e
well you're right about that all right
let's get the freak out of here why did
we come here why would this be where we
go oh it was right there why did we do
this I almost didn't make that I was
outside for a second don't worry it only
gets worse here what do you mean hey
guys good warm up hi yeah what hey
man what's up how's it going you guys
seem to be having some serious troubles
in that in that place um yeah it was
rough I I did manage to bring back one
little bit of loot yeah we got we've got
a little bit of loot I really should
have grabbed something on the on my
Sprint but I really did the horror movie
thing I thought you were dead Mark I I I
just ran for it straight up didn't know
where I was going just went for it and
uh I made it where are
we we took off thinking that oh uh we're
back in the same place Mark why this is
we paid to come here it's
expensive recharge your stuff boys I
guess yep see guys you're right you're
right all right all right Mark let's go
all right radio check yeah let's go
check
check there's a house just off to the
left somewhere here right here yeah here
that's
uh wait
wait did you just hear W voice I did
yeah I dude I I don't
know I'm going to just go into the to
the thing yeah I'm going to go into the
thing did you go I'm in the
thing what I'm in the
building hello hello yeah hello oh okay
I don't know what happen where's
Wade yeah I don't I don't I don't know
where Wade
went well that's I I picked up teeth but
they're
chattering what is that
sound what is
that I'm here up well I've got so many
noisy things I'm just going to go back
to the ship because holy
[__] yeah noisy things are bad yeah I
got
them Mark just checking out ran away
it's not exactly chickening out I just I
had
loot
uh I just dropped an
engine I just dropped an engine
outside thank you for the gentle chuckle
I appreciate that I didn't laugh who was
laughing I'm pretty sure blade was
laughing at you chicken
man I did
over okay whatever um I'm going to stay
in the the the ship cuz uh I can give
you guys
guidance
okay that's a little unnecessary I am
doing a good job and I this is a
valuable listen Bob when you need a
rescue I'm not going to teleport you oh
you're going to teleport me you're going
to no I'm not going to teleport you I'm
not going to do it you're going to
teleport me right now you want to
teleport right now well obviously
not hey Mark if you're going to be at
the ship we could possibly use some more
help uh car
stuff okay yeah not so funny now is it
huh yeah oh look you're I did the thing
oh I did it I did all right this is well
that was a little reductive wait what's
your
status I'm good but I found Bob
stuff yeah I I uh he yeah I teleported
him it's fine we have three two-handed
objects here so we we have to make some
trips soon I'll come back grab another
it doesn't look like anything was nearby
hello
hello guys I took a wrong turn
somewhere uh Mark we didn't pass you you
took a wrong turn yeah I I don't I don't
know where I am okay Mark go to your
left
okay turn to your right turning
right straight uh no to to your right a
little bit straight that
way you stop moving there there's a
wall it's like a dead end mark would you
like to be teleported back no I'm fine I
I I think I'm near I must be getting
near a fire exit or
something not that I can
see Mark are you using your right click
to
scan uh yeah it's kind of like low
visibility out here I I don't know what
I'm doing uh but okay keep going keep
going the direction you're going and try
to go left when you
can
okay okay uh don't go that way don't go
that way turn around oh oh what do you
mean what do you mean what do you
mean oh here's a building this is the
direction don't go that way oh I was
trying to go into the
place yes that's to your left you just
need to follow the lights to the left go
to the
place I know there's a shortcut here
Cuts right
through well that's where you were you
said you were lost well no no that's not
where I was well I was trying to find it
but I wasn't I got it I'm
here yeah guys I just want to say I'm
sorry for the hostility I I I I realize
like I'm being for you there's a tree
person guarding the
ship Mark your side is safe if you can
approach the ship quickly it's on the
opposite
side oh okay hey a picture of Ryan
Reynolds oh oh my God I was good um Bob
is dead
wait
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
bad oh his head's a spring oh my God go
yes leave yeah yeah I think go I think
go okay all right go go
go I
what
um well at least he's happy all right
good
was that a scream that sounded like a
scream but we're in space so what hi
guys hi hello again hey I heard that
scream what was that scream that I don't
don't know I do not
know well we have lots of good loot also
hey Wayne you know how you thought the
footsteps might be gone on that one
thing oh not they are no they are that's
what that's what killed me there's no
footsteps anymore um we do have I I'll
buy some extra walkies but we do have
shovels I can buy a couple more supplies
before we go down I would like to be
Shipman today what okay you could be
shovel you could be Shipman but Wade has
suggested the shovel strategy many times
and it's never worked out for us I just
want to point that out it works fine no
the shovel totally works it works works
all right I know that planet kind of
sucked yeah and maybe we should another
one okay we're going
back
I thought we were having fun I'm glad we
decided that democratically good work
all right I'm going to go get my walkie
bought the walk right I bought two
walkies two shovel and two pro
flashlights okay I'm gunning it
[Music]
inside Mark do you want a
sh no I'm just going to do the thing I
normally do which is run in grab as much
as I can never go back in I respect
it there's a there's a present right
away I'm not touching
that the present presents are good all
right there just a small chance of
presents being bad we got incredibly
unlucky the very first
present okay I got a magnifying glass
loot Mark here right in that room this
another loot no no uh Under the
Stairs yeah you're looking at it Mark
something yep yeah it's a
cup Roger
Roger number one
mug
yeah yo what's
up
oh did you just open a present right in
front of me hoping that it would kill me
I did well not hoping it would kill you
but I did open a present in front of you
in the chance all right I'm just giving
Mark a present
over
yeah it was a brush
thankfully uh OverWatch any uh eyes on
items whoa that's
negatory hearing some on a dead end
there mark yeah but I'm hearing some
strange Rolling Wood sounds doesn't
sound
healthy no uh enemies on the scope
either you're doing all right
okay uh wait did you head upstairs oh
yeah yeah I left a shovel and a key by
the front door we them no it's just an
empty doorway on my
screen good job thanks I'm going to run
this back to the ship I'm full
up um Mark I are you do you have any
two-handers uh I no but I'm going
anyway and it's not because I'm a
chicken it's not it's not in fact I'd
say there's one person amongst us that
is uh replicating the actions of a
chicken much more than I am to the
left uh to your right and then left
right around the corner left uh no no no
no no no no
Noles hi Mark how's it going it's good I
forgot to recharge I'm coming
back no no no go back oh Bob I I forgot
about this
too that's for
you than babe all right wait I'm coming
back
in chicken found his guts that doesn't
make any sense because if chicken found
its guts it would be on the outside of
its body and therefore it would be dying
which I am not you can find things
metaphorically chicken so
dumb I'm sorry Mark are you spinning in
circles right
now I am not really I I picked up some
stuff outside hey wait what does it mean
if there's another blue character in the
building spinning in circles and where
you are but Mark isn't in
there it means nothing good for me where
is that oh you're it wasn't on the other
side of like the main hall upstairs it
was across the balcony upstairs Far Far
Away actually it's way closer now
actually interesting it's right there no
behind you wa there's your friend
Mark yep it's me um I've got a lot of
bad you want to watch you want to
watch yeah I can watch
suff uh-huh oh look look at all the
friends Wade has those aren't us wow
look at him just making friends without
us yeah you got a you got an
issue yeah that's not you might want to
come back uh buddy yeah just come on
back look at him taking the long way oh
sorry [__] look look at him taking the
long way what an idiot what an idiot
yeah that's stupid fool that's stupid
idiot fool man I see the shortcut you've
been taking it's so much faster and it
almost never ends up with you getting
lost yeah it happened you know my my
ratio is pretty good Mark I stuff I left
some more stuff on the stairs I might
need another hand to grab it all what's
up should we should we all go back
should should we yeah let's do that all
right okay yeah Mark let's let's go
let's go have a look look A Rooney all
right
fine I was it just bad luck on the other
two trips here or was is this how it's
supposed to
be H I think it was probably kind of bad
luck is anyone following me in my
amazing
shortcut huh friends
oh huh
Mar oh wow you guys finally made it oh
wait wait wait a minute that that wait
wait wait wait wait wa wait wait a
minute wait a minute wait wait uh H bad
bad bad we woo we woo we
woo
uh uh yeah full red we woo there's a lot
of stuff here
guys oh my God why are you
here opening the door I'm open sh W woo
I have a shovel I have a
[Music]
shovel